ايران تشغل العالم بما يجري في الداخل
وبينشطتها في الخارج ايضا فالمسيرات
الايرانيه تخلق ازمه تمتد من امريكا وصولا
الى اوكرانيا مرورا عبر روسيا فهي باتت
صداعا في راس الولايات المتحده سيما وان
مكونات هذه المسيارات مكونات امريكيه
مهربه تستخدم في صناعه هذه المسيارات
واشنطن تريد ان تضع حدا لهذه المسيارات
وهذا ما اكتشفت عنه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
التي قالت بان الاداره الامريكيه تبذل
جهودا كبيرا للحد من قدره ايران على انتاج
وتسليم سيارات الى روسيا والتي تستخدمها
ضد اوكرانيا وتشيل التقارير الى ان طهران
زودت القوات الروسيه حتى الان بنحو 1700
طائره هجوميه بدون طيار
وتخطط لتزويدها ب 300 اخرى في المستقبل
القريب
ملف المسيرات الايرانيه باتا مصدر ازعاج
حقيقي للولايات المتحده التي كانت فتحت
تحقيقا بخصوص تهريب المكونات الغربيه شبكه
سي ان ان قالت الى ان ايران تجد وفره من
التكنولوجيا المتاحه تجاريا على الرغم من
فضل عقوبه صارمه عليها كما ان هذه
المكونات المستخدمه لا تقتصر فقط على تلك
الشركات او التي تنتجها الشركات الامريكيه
حيث تم العثور على مكونات مصنعه في بلدان
اخرى مثل البطاريات يابانيه ومحرك نمساوي
[موسيقى]